cientos de trabajadores inmigrantes en
las calles de doha celebrando el mundial
que se acerca algunos llevan más de 10
años levantando los escenarios donde se
jugará Qatar 2022 la situación de los
trabajadores inmigrantes en el emirato
rico en petróleo ha sido el centro de la
polémica de esta copa del mundo los
petrodólares de Qatar han atraído mano
de obra de Asia y África los migrantes
representan ahora más del 80% de la
población del país estos trabajadores
que han construido los estadios y otras
infraestructuras se alojan en remotas e
insalubres ciudades dormitorio tras 24
se reunió con varios de ellos que
afirmaron no haber recibido su salario
en meses
todos los días nos prometen que nos van
a dar el sueldo pero no nos lo dan la
empresa nos ha quitado todos los
pasaportes que debemos hacer aquí esto
es esclavitud esto es una especie de
prisión están abusando de los Derechos
Humanos
largas jornadas de trabajo tengas un
calor sofocante a menudo sin límite de
tiempo y por salarios y risorios
condiciones denunciadas por varias ong
Qatar aplicó algunas reformas a partir
de 2018 pero tres años después sugardien
reveló que 6.500 trabajadores
extranjeros han muerto desde la
adjudicación del mundial
cifras que duja han negado con
rotundidad mundo
Qatar se ha enfrentado a una campaña de
críticas sin precedentes como ningún
otro país
muchos se preguntan por las verdaderas
motivaciones de estos ataques
y algunas federaciones nacionales de
fútbol han pedido que se cree un fondo
para compensar a las familias de los
trabajadores que han muerto durante las
obras del mundial pero
Qatar se opone firmemente